when it comes to television getting a
pilot greenlit by the network is usually
good news for everyone involved
unfortunately for these stars though
their appearances in the first round of
filming for an eventual hit show didn't
pan out because they were replaced
before their series went into full
production whether it was professional
conflicts or personal matters these
actors lost what became pretty iconic
small screen roles
despite filming them first here are some
TV characters who were recast after the
pilot The Incredible Hulk
Lou Ferrigno became a household name
thanks to his successful run as the Mean
Green Monster in the classic 70s TV
series but it was originally Richard
keel who'd signed up to star as the Hulk
the eventual James Bond villain was
hired to film two movies of the week
that were to serve as the pilot for the
proposed series however keel who was
blind in one eye was uncomfortable in
the full contact lenses that the part
required and also didn't like the green
body paint producers also felt that keel
didn't fit perfectly in the part since
even though he was over seven feet tall
he didn't boast a bodybuilder physique
the role was eventually given to
Ferrigno but keels turn is still briefly
visible in the scene in which Hulk saves
a young girl from drowning Danny Tanner
Full House almost had a different dad
John Posey was initially brought on to
play the role of Danny Tanner on the
popular sitcom but he was replaced by
comedian Bob Saget after filming the
pilot Posey had just two credits to his
name when he signed on for the pilot and
said he was actually on his way from
Atlanta to Los Angeles to work on the
series when he got the call saying he
had been replaced
show creator Jeff Franklin wanted either
Saget or Paul Reiser from the beginning
but they both been tied up with other
potential shows neither Paul nor Bob
were interested we went through a
casting process we ended up casting a
complete unknown when Saget became
available however Franklin decided to
give Posey the ax and I just I don't
know as soon as I created this character
I thought Bob Posey still went on to
have a very successful career as a small
screen guest star however he's nowhere
near as well-known as the man who became
America's dad on the beloved sitcom
Sookie st. James before she became such
a big-screen sensation Melissa McCarthy
was perhaps best known for her role as
the sweet Stars Hollow chef Sookie st.
James on Gilmore
girls however the actress almost wasn't
chosen to wear Sookie's signature smock
in the series unaired pilot comedic
actress Alex Borstein originally
appeared in the role but had to back
away due to her contract with MADtv
hoarse teen still got to appear on the
show just in a much smaller role instead
of playing sookie the actress made a
couple of cameos as the sharp tongued
harp player Drella and then reemerged as
the family stylist miss Celine Willow
Rosenberg Buffy the Vampire Slayer's
original pilot is actually surfaced
which means that fans can go back and
watch the original Willow Rosenberg in
action to see why another actress was
brought in to play her Alyson Hannigan
would famously go on to take over the
part but it was riff Regan who'd starred
in the short pilot creator Joss Whedon
made for the network in a bid to get the
show picked up the network had a few
issues with the pilot and one of the big
points was Regan who played a much more
quiet and subdued version of the
character than the one fans would come
to know in the show's full run Daenerys
Targaryen Emilia Clarke's portrayal of
Khaleesi is a major part of why Game of
Thrones is one of the most popular shows
on TV but she wasn't the first actor
brought on to play the part of the
mother of dragons that honor instead
went to Tamzin merchant an english
actress known for her role in the Tudors
while we don't know exactly why merchant
was let go after the pilot Game of
Thrones showrunners Stan Weiss and David
Benioff have been pretty open in their
discussions about the shortcomings of
the original pilot which had to be
almost completely reshot so that it
could eventually become such a massive
cultural phenomenon so thank you Catelyn
Stark Daenerys wasn't the only game of
Thrones role to be recast after the
pilot actress Jennifer L was initially
set to play stark family matriarch
Catelyn but she ended up dropping out of
the role which eventually went to
Michelle Fairley l stepped away from the
role because it involved a seven-year
contract and at the time her daughter
was just a few months old the show's
producers ended up having fairly reshoot
all of the scenes involving Elle and the
rest is history
Jenna Moroney Jane Krakowski earned four
Emmy Award nominations for her role as
30 Rock's resident diva Jenna Maroney
but it turns out that the character was
originally supposed to be a little
different
creator Tina Fey originally cast her
former Saturday Night Live co-star
Rachel Dratch in the role but the part
was given to Krakowski
after NBC saw the shows unaired pilot
drachez version of the role was still
Liz's best friend in the star of the
girlie show but the series would have
originally focused more on sketches
Dratch was later told the series style
was moving more toward that of a sitcom
meaning they needed an actress who could
fit that bill naturally she was upset
about the decision when you think about
planning your SNL exit you don't think
like I know I'll leave and have a big
public faceplant
but Dratch did go on to hold a number of
other roles on the show including the
overwhelmed cat Wrangler Greta the Happy
Days obsessed cleaning lady Maria and
the imaginary blue man Sarah Braverman
after becoming America's hippest mom
Lorelei on Gilmore Girls
Lauren Graham again captured the hearts
of small screen audiences everywhere as
Sarah Braverman on NBC's Parenthood
however er star maura Tierney originally
occupied that role before having to drop
out under terrible circumstances after
filming the pilot she learned that she
had breast cancer the show's producers
tried to accommodate her treatments by
pushing back production and sending the
show's premier to mid-season but in the
end it was too much for her and she had
to leave the show in her place Graham
was brought on to take over the part and
after Tierney recovered she went on to
nab an award-winning role on the hit
show time series the affair
[Music]